good morning ladies and gentlemen we
welcome you to the
press conference away from balance 1 and
we are particularly pleased to welcome you all on site
after a
completely digital yes last year
so
we would like to thank a
science center berlin for
social research  that we
are allowed to continue this press conference today
for all those who are connected online,
thank you very much for being there,
we are very happy and you can also
ask your questions in the live chat and
we would be happy to take you to the second part of
our press conference in the
question and answer session of
our panel guests  today the
governing mayor of berlin and
senator for science and research
michael müller are
coordinator of cool and sciences young
lineg president of
science center berlin for
social research and founding
coordinator jo net social and
humanities berlin research
five the jutta allmendinger
team is sw  he
academic director of
ex partner research partnership
hobby dedicates communication director his
set knows for policy at european academy
and well and says managing director of the
title project the 611 week starts with
a milestone with a festival
program of over 200 different
events and we are very happy about some
highlights  to present it to you
today and i would like to hand over the
floor to michael müller
yes many thanks a nice good
morning
here at the wzb but of course also
one who is tuned in and i
hope that together we can get everyone
excited for the next
science weighs the  Ahead of us is the
sixth suite in our city,
but you have to say it in the meantime
, which is internationally recognized
by the many international
cooperation partners and guests that we
have so far beyond our city,
this 1 victory and a
big thank you in this one too
connection to professor m  unich to his
whole team to the many alliance partners,
including those from falling walls, of course, who
once again did an excellent job of coordinating this, putting
together a great program,
we will have over 200 events
, 500 active top
scientists, of course,
but also many from companies in
related
political and scientific fields, and
we have  i think the
museum for natural history will again be the central
campus not all of the city will be there, but
many events, exhibitions,
discussions will also take place there
and we have all already experienced
together
that it is a place that is enthusiastically
beautiful that we can do this  being able to embed a branch
in 114
2021 was really a great year of
science it can maybe
you can still say that it is depressing of
course still due to this
corona time and the effects of the
whole fight against the pandemic but
we noticed the same as just now  during this
time, also due to the media support,
there was a lot of interest
in science and in the work of
scientists as well as people who
had never come into contact with it before
suddenly became interested in
science programs on tv and
read the articles podcast
sounds good and i keep saying
i think it's great because of a not-so-
nice topic, but how suddenly
this intra gave this interest and
attention to the
work of scientists,
and at that
moment, i think many of them really
felt
how  this work is important and it influences our
daily life in the
corona period we all noticed anyway
health care would not have been
possible vaccine development
would not have been possible by
scientists
but many
have int  we
really noticed the wide range of topics
that science and
research influence our daily life
together and we were also able to honor 21 scientists in this
knowledge year science year 20 20
namely
hermann von helmholtz and ruder will who
celebrated their 200th birthday
with those here on the
we were able to partially sit on the podium
open-air exhibition and public
discussions invited
to experience science again up close in front of the red town hall
and i think that also
inspired many and yesterday evening
we continued yesterday evening in the red town hall we had the work
made women scientists visible
we were able to welcome great women to the red town hall
who today stand for top
scientists and
top-level research, but we
also made it clear
how women have advanced science over the last 100 years
and unfortunately often not
h  were sufficiently appreciated and were
seen with their work yesterday,
we took a first and a further step forward with an initiative through the
cooperation with the BH changed
wikipedia entries
and also to appreciate this great work
more clearly and better,
so found its goal in this one  and finds
many excellent city design suite
is there certainly another
highlight from the first to tenth eleventh
will take place, although we
will cheat a bit this year, i want to say
that in conclusion, because we are
already doing something on 30 10 on 30 10
she will  give an event in the
urania tabula rasa we
invite the berliners
to let themselves be inspired with
discussion formats and information
formats in the urania a
scientific institution also the urania
which is an important partner for us to
above all also
scientific topics in  the society
to v  investigating i think that should
always be our common aspiration,
also for the
scientists to work on it so that
more and more people see the work
, appreciate and support it
and we will also award the berlin science prize on 5 november is
even then
, as always
, we reveal  not yet like him the
two prizewinners will be the main one
who gets the main prize and the young talent prize
but in the last
few years it has also received a lot more
attention it is also
nice that people see how the
science metropolis berlin and
those who are active here in  in
science and research
we work together with many partners how
this is becoming more and more in the context of this
award ceremony i think it was always
very good to experience so
once again a big
thank you to everyone involved for what
was once again put together  a
big s  Step forward and I
very much hope that, like in previous
years, we can now be present again,
not only online or hybrid,
but also in person, that we
can inspire many to be there.
I cordially invite you all,
thank you very much, Mr  müller
maybe a short message for
international press representatives who are tuned in
i say the english of
the premiere live stream
that's
thanks a lot good morning also from my
side
the governing mayor has
basically
already said a lot of what i should have said
I don't want to repeat the number of events and so on, but first of all I want to say
a big thank
you to him personally and
to the Berlin Senate for the really
long-term and growing support
that we have also experienced here with Berlin Science
without the
support of the  landes berlin
we wouldn't be where we are today s  and from
there a
very, very big thank you to you personally, mr. müller,
the thanks go further to those who
are sitting here on the stage because this
balance a suite is a
joint event
of, if you will,
science of research of those
who are involved with the innovation
system  the goal is ultimately to make the balance
1 way, together with the von den
boards conference, a world
meeting point for those who are
convinced that science,
research and innovation is for the future of
our society and also for the
future of our planet, that sounds slightly pathetic
important are why i say that, to
put it bluntly, science has
saved the world's
butt in the last 15 months, that's the way it is and i
believe that it has also been generally
accepted,
and that's why science,
research, innovation,
finally also expressly includes the
economy and the  politics with a di  e
science alone would not have
made this vaccine available so quickly
it was an
interaction of science,
business and politics that made this
possible has shown the power
of science, research and
innovation I am often asked
why science and my answer is
always satisfaction  Human
curiosity is
the usual thing, but the other thing is
securing our livelihoods and
I think science has
really made a contribution to this in the last 15 to 18 months
in connection with this
pandemic. I'm sure that
this will also be the case with other
topics  it will be on the subject of
climate change that will be on the subject of
supplying energy that will be on the
subject of sustainability science
will play its part and i hope
that the people who have experienced what is
possible will also
give their support for this we have
this year again  a wonderful
supplement balance 1 way there you
can look in and see
all the events the
government has said 200 events
two days again concentrated in the
museum for natural history
science campus we have contributions
from berlin institutions of the berlin
university alliance above all fertilizer
is also for them  50 non-university
research institutions that
show once again how much horsepower they bring to the road
also for and then
Germany as a location but especially for berlin
we have the international alliance of
academies we have on board here which
I think there is also a lot of expectation
behind it also in connection  especially
with the topic of science research and
innovation
this goal to make it a special place here
wants to get away from
the boards conference for isar 1 world
meeting place in science ladies and gentlemen
only works together that's why it's so important
that you also bring many different
areas together wi  r have to
show the next generation young
people are important so that the topic of
science, research and innovation can
progress we have to make it clear
what added value arises from the topic
patents intellectual property new
jobs that’s also an aspect and of
course the topic of communication it
doesn’t help in the deepest sense  coal cellar
burning off fireworks nobody sees that
we have to show what we achieve
and also present it
publicly in enthusiastic formats that
's kind of the idea behind the balance
1 victory and what's connected with it
from there many thanks again for the
commitment of the  thank you very much because we
really can only create something special together
thank you
received thanks to hermlin ecke jutta
allmendinger please have a
nice day i come from munich i am currently
working in munich at the center
for advanced studies and when i had my
first professorship in 1992 in
munich munich was the definitive one  capital  dt
of science in Germany and when
I said I'm taking the day off today I
want to go to Berlin today then they
said I should because the one-sided
Berlin is just fine now that's I
don't even want to say that's better
because science is always something inclusive for me
is science knows no
national borders it also knows no
borders along gender
along origin along nationality
and i said you can all
come along we can go to
berlin together and celebrate science together in berlin
and the
scientists in what they
have achieved  but also in what they
will achieve, exactly what I
just said about removing boundaries, that also
applies in an interdisciplinary manner, we have
seen how many different
sciences were affected by the
corona crisis and how much all these
sciences together are about people’s
trust in  Germany and worldwide
are fighting  must have fought well
i would say great motto also
fought successfully the more inclusive
we are the better who succeeds
and that's why part of this
berlins 1 way
will take care of exactly this inclusive thing it will take care of
the inclusive along the gender
you all know  we still have far too
few female professors in our
top positions in berlin is also a
pioneer because
more than 50 percent of those appointed are women it is
really a sign that we are not only setting
national but also
international standards and because we always
emphasize that it is possible  these
women are there that they
need the trust that maybe one
or the other
thing has to be arranged differently because the natural development of
people into science is
anything but natural with
long,
unlimited employment activities
with the renunciation of family and so
on and  so on we can do everything
better  doing and bringing science from
all countries together also has
this component which structural
framework conditions allow
these talents to be challenged at all and
it's not just about gender it's
about diversity in general for me that was
something I
would like to add to that  diversity thought
this interdisciplinary teetz thought
is also why we succeeded with a lot of strength
and with a lot of
support
without question and many many thanks for
getting all of the non-university
institutions in berlin under one roof
it
doesn't matter whether they are max planck
institutions the Frauenhofer Helmholtz
Leibnitz department  research institutions
and that works and we get to know each other,
the doctoral students, the
post docs but also those who have
made it and that is also a
piece of inclusive activity which then
allows us to work with the universities in a completely different
way, namely
not against each other, as
the non-university against
the university is often called, but together,
inclusion is the
key word and in this direction the wzb,
together with others, is offering
two events at once
something i'm very proud of, i know how
i managed to persuade private donors to
also
award social science prizes, which
don't happen at all with the nobel
prizes, although this year's economists are also doing
quite a lot of
social science research
when they look at causal things in the effects
of minimum wage and second
but we have a so-called
hsk prize endowed with 200,000 euros
and this prize will be awarded here on november 2nd
and with carola lenz the
president of the goethe
assembly it is wonderful that
we have a great laudator that
others are turning i  When I was
more than 50 about diversity in the theater of universe
uniformity and what is behind it
I had actually already presented it is directed
from very different disciplines
by people of very different
ages origin gender that
will also take place on 5 November 21 at 6 p.m.
we look forward to it that is  a
small excerpt of what
we watch together, what we knew about the
time and i don't know how many times
i have thanked mr. müller because
i always think it will be the last time
that i will sit next to him in his
berlin event but it
probably is  or I hope it
won't be the last time again, but one
cannot thank you enough for this yes, where did
Berlin do, which became
so clear to me when my
eyebrows were raised in Munich this morning
, why I am
now going to Berlin to the science city
I know I was late it
wasn't just me thank you very
much  thanks mrs allmendinger
next jmstv academic director
magdeburgern research partners
please yes hello everyone i have
been the academic director of the oxid berlin research partnership since the beginning of the year
and this partnership has
been around since 2000
and
mr müller müllers and i would also like to thank you on behalf of
the partnership for this
support the
partnership is trying to build up robust
cooperation between the university of
oxford and the universities and institutions here in the berlin area and will fund
projects for
projects as well as
female scientists exchange and in the future we will also try to set up a female
and female student exchange
the research areas covered by the
partnership are the
natural sciences, nature, the
social sciences as well as
the humanities and
medicine  So we are a very
broad-based partnership
and science excellent
science is based on cooperation
and partnerships, so this
partnership that berlin is trying to
build up with oxford university is a
very important contribution to the excellence
of science here in the berlin area
significantly in the positive or to
improve it will be an enrichment it
is an enrichment of the scientific
work here in the berlin
area so when we
started as academic director
we were right in the middle of the pandemic that
means a cooperation a
link a partnership between
england and berlin in kuwait  where you
could no longer travel was of course a
very big
[music]
challenge for us and
our way of working has
also changed a lot as a result, so
we pushed the partnership
forward in Suhl meetings at
regular intervals and were also  n able to
set up new structures and that
brings me to the next topic, which
wanted to be highlighted here, so
posco witt, science such as
experimental particles physicist and
all our conferences were canceled
we only
held larger conferences in zoom all our
analysis  work meetings at took place
virtually, that means the
working environment my workplace
has changed a lot and I will also
now post cupid this matter so our working relationship will change a lot
both in the sciences and
in society,
which brings opportunities, that means
having this change  created
equal rights, for
example, for people who cannot always
travel to switzerland to be at
my laboratory, for example,
could participate much better in the
work and like that it also has an
effect, such as work life
balance or occupational health and
safety issues  en of course also be acute in the
future and in this context
I would like to mention the fair work
project, which is funded via the oxid
berlin partnership.
the funding started in the sitcom
program of the oxid berlin partnership
and it is now also being carried out during
the global challenge
Promotion of the der oxe berlin
partnership also further promoted and
this chassis project deals
with platforms economy and the and very
fair working conditions of
these workers and
accordingly i think you will also introduce
yourself here in the context of
science like koch and if
questions if you have questions the
two project participants are also sitting here
in the audience
that's actually what i
wanted
to say thanks
the word go on to top be the head of
communication
[music]
with
here dear thanks top  portman, more precisely, I
might briefly return to the
science fiction a  offer on 05 06
november in the natural
history museum that is called berlins 1 with campos this year
there are 30 events and hermann
kratt has already presented exactly 30 of them event
12 exhibitions and here of course
we are welcome to visit there too and
we come to our last guest well
and says managing director of the tegel project,
please yes, i might be
adding application-centric research and science to how we do it, we are here on the former
airport, an area, a model quarter,
where, in the context of climate change, we are
tempted to show how
cities can be in the future and that’s where we want to be
what is possible in science in research
really burns into the
application as a model that is
particularly important to us we have three
elements here at the former airport
that is the urbantec republic where
we really from the research from the
university to the start-up  then the
way up to an industrial band al  so
have a very small granulation and then
try to build up a
trade of a production chain
up to the industry then i have to
do that quarter as a residential quarter here
we want it to become one of the largest wooden
residential quarters in europe we
really want a change in the construction
industry and in building  von randen
bring you know about climate change you
mentioned earlier we have
to completely rethink building, and i’m an
architect by trade and now I’m responsible
for planning and building and also for this
implementation, so to speak, we also
work very intensively, for example
with words  together we will consider
how we can manage the production
chains so that we can, for example, in
timber construction, independently of the international
international market, we will
assemble the apple cider system, we are considering how,
so to speak, we can bring the wood directly from
the forests to the airfield and to the
district and the best thing
is of course the the  science  t the
technology we are very good in Germany
we have really great engineers
bold but often
so to speak the contracts the
administrations that are difficult
but we have them with the system of an in-
house model an assignment where,
so to speak, with the state-owned forest
to the state-owned
housing associations give a
model where we can also work very
cheaply just as an
example
innovative urban technologies that is
very important for the
future urban development for
resource-saving smart
urban development and we want to
create models here that work for
berlin-brandenburg
but then of course they do
can also be used as an example in other
places around the world
that is our
goal in tegel to try out things that
we can then use
somewhere else on a
larger scale yes
that we will start this end of this
year early next year with the
first  n procedure we now had a
long time to plan and are very happy
that we are now really starting the
training the b plans for the
first construction phase are there and yes it
is starting now in tegel said many
thanks to mrs sack and we are handing
over thus  for the second part of
our press conference a round of questions
and we already have a question,
please, i think we have
a microphone for this,
our
thank you, trust me, but i
have a question first,
please give a summary of
the two previous years 2019 2020 how many
participants  did you
have something there that you took over from 2020 that was a
virtual event for
this year 20 21 so how many digital
elements do you have in it
third question what about the claim
you only briefly mentioned the
world science sa mez
how do you implement that how
how do you put this world claim above
and for the question of
financing what does the berlins be
egg  n trick how much money do you have at
your disposal who is it from
[music]
dear sir we have us i am
always happy to answer your questions
i will try it in a quick way
20 19 balance 1 how 20,000
participants
look at mrs brummer 130 140
events
she raises  thumbs up
last year we
reinvented ourselves didn't say we're
transforming this week or the three
days of falling walls one-to-one into the
digital say we said we'd
just use the digital world
to do events beforehand so we
split that up  all in all, with
the aim of increasing the reach via digitization, i.e. video,
we had a total of 65,000 participants last year
and we said we want
stronger active participation,
which led us to
log out a so-called global call for
breakthroughs in  ten categories
last year we had 1009 theirs from
wasn't it 130 140 countries
from all over the world in the ten categories,
where we then identified ten winners and
one breakthrough among the winners
, we did that
again this year, which means we
basically reached 1000 active participants in one fell swoop
via
institutions such as stanford harvard
oxford eth  Zurich but also companies
foundations only foundation john sakaluk
foundation volkswagen foundation and so
on and are going hybrid this year, that
means we have a
face-to-face event with fewer
participants we usually have around
1000 forwards this time it’s more like
500 because we have to comply with the hygiene
rules  at
balance 1, away from the 200
events, will the majority be
hybrid or will only 25 percent be digital, i
think i really are
face-to-face events, which will of course
also be broadcast, that means we
are really trying to combine the best of both
worlds, so hybrid
nomination active participation
high  select a
top-class jury and then hold a three-day on-site event
financing heavily public funds
this also applies to the Bullen Science
weighs almost exclusively with
funds from the state of berlin but not only
but almost exclusively with long
funds from
the state of berlin the state of berlin is involved  but in the case of
vornholz, for example, the same as the
bmbf
in the financing, so heavily public funds,
the other half
are funds from foundations such as the
bosch foundation, but also from
companies, so that we are fifty-fifty
financed, 50 percent public 50
percent private
in total  you assume
that this event
will cost around two million euros you
should perhaps add but
you know that we are required is
non-profit and the role is also important
to say thanks again to the team
here, the largest in government
that we curated as already mentioned  the balance
1 weighs the i  the reason for the balance 1 way is
that as many people as possible take part in their
own name and that
events were held here and now i
have forgotten another question that you
asked, also in a
quick run-through why the claim to do something really globally visible here we have america on the  on the one hand the
usa we have asia with japan china on
the other hand we are of the opinion that
we also need
a place in europe for science and research
that stands for this topic also with
regard to the topic of innovation i.e.
value creation from science and
research
everything and  there we are of the opinion
in the heart of europe in berlin under
this still strong brand of the falling
wall walls are being built everywhere
the falling walls we also have a
brand that is becoming more and more
noticeable worldwide and
the claim in the end is to be
with the balance  speed or the
summit here in berlin to become what
there where it for  the economy or the
munich security conference for the
security politicians is the
meeting place where you just have to be
and only talk about the big future
topics
thanks mr mit den way i think
we actually had a question please
nice
scary nice
days one more question to the whole  podium for
me it is not yet
clear what the program
highlights are you have presented your institutions or your approaches here it
is now difficult not only for me
but also for the people out there
to determine
where the event is, of course there is
it  Nice brochure but
when I cook back there I have
a bit of the suspicion that
partly or to a large extent you have
to constantly register that you
have to make a
contribution that costs something that
you had to or can accredit for a long time beforehand
click on each and then see what it is so
e  it's an eerie hodgepodge of
different events it's probably
not very clear where it's very
public now it's in the
natural history museum and if so where can
I find what's taking place there
so I can perhaps briefly fail
to go to the natural history museum
but mrs brummer can  add
two days if you want i think the fifth
and sixth in the museum for
natural history where you meet
especially those who want to do face-to-face events
there is a lot on the net
and i think you just have
to make the effort here and then see what
interests you  me actually from the
topics and where I would like
to say then
somehow switch in that works digitally very
well what specifically concerns the front of the bib now
we have the three-year-old we
have to be careful in the radial system that
we only let a certain number of people in
we said
3g because we also take tested
ones we have
man  And foreigners also come who take
other vaccines than those that
are readily recognized
here, which means that we also have to
test them, which means this year the
access control is again special
, like the individual
colleagues then do at their
events  that is always a
matter for those who organize the event
so we can ask
for this query we
actually didn't want it to be that we
have a central venue for one reason it's also
an event for the
city society we wanted there and
there i would be thresholds are higher or
lower for the person from berlin
who comes by and therefore also
this difference where you get there
how you get there but also of
course lower access points in
the digital space but that also of
course selectively again for others
so that was at  design and therefore
with your question can  let's think about it
again whether it might be better
to have a venue we actually wanted to
distribute it
I come here as a journalist
to find out what's what
specifically let's say 10
program highlights I'll
definitely find out
but it's incredibly difficult to
see, so i did
n't find out in an hour what's actually happening
in the natural history museum, for
example, i know that the
federal institute for material research is also
doing something, then i'll assume
that it's generally publicly
accessible but if it is  If there is a falling walls
conference panel anyway, then I
assume that not all
citizens can go there,
so with von den boards there are also the main events that
are streamed
, you can watch them if
you want, but I think we have to do it
a bit  get away from it all being served so
truly bite sized that we
tell you now so there are 200
events and you have to go to
five now that's not an
enlightened approach to the whole
story i just want to point it out to you
but i
expect when this offer is there that
you'll see what interests me
now  is it more humanities and social
science it is the topic of
battery research for me it is the topic of
climate change for me and then i watch aha
climate change there is a
podium discussion
with edenhofer here from pick
i would like to attend anzag then spend
half an hour there  and
maybe stay an hour or
say goodbye after a
quarter of an hour because they say boring well
this this this claim
that everything has to be
sorted again somehow for each individual
with highlights I just have a
problem with I would say the
goal is here  really the spectrum of
what science research
offers  t to explain in full
and
to leave it up to each individual what interests
me now and then to make the selection
I could go here like
everyone here on the podium and advertise for
somehow now before the boards events that women can do
,
especially in the end  how eg can you do
woman is so much more for the berlin
university alliance and so on but
immediately everyone answered that a little differently
let me tell you hits i would
say that we can all put our hand in
the fire that the individual
event is well curated and  that's
why we didn't do a
best of by design here either that's the
event where the figureheads
come of course they then have
the practice on them at falling walls here
you can see who made the very
long selection i was allowed to head one of these
selection committees  that's
a tough task to have to choose among the best
. we have
e  something like the best freestyle if you because
but otherwise i would for the
events with which i was tangentially involved
or which
i was allowed to do the impression
that we all tried very
hard that because of this
range very good event  is
because even after the interest goes exactly
maybe just a moment from me i
can give you the hard facts
also about the program so i let
others in any case i think
the idea of the festival 11 away in itself is th
science in every
ne  to show facets we have ten thematic blocks
we have over 200 events we
have over 500
speakers as already mentioned
the falling post events
too, for example, they are all broadcast
free of charge via live stream when
it comes to science we also have the balance sheet
already discussed,
mostly digital or hybrid or
with simply registering  i us on
the homepage of
each event has, among other things
, a short description of whether you have to
register online or on site so
that’s clear for a reader and i
think
everyone who goes to our site can do it
very, very easily and very quickly
for themselves  also clarify
do you want to add
anything marquez was many thanks we have
one more question
i have two more questions for
mr müller this is probably your
last public appearance as
science senator of berlin
short short reflex what do you wish for
or what you don't have ready  get
what absolutely
needs to be done in this city in terms of science policy then outlook
federal parliament you want to get involved in
science policy there where
we are now here with the balance 1
you will work there to
ensure that this event is
rolled out nationwide and possibly we
have also a hardware already in
this stad  t the humboldt forum, which
is filled with completely antiquated things,
that there may be
a combination with this
event, so a look into the
future, how do you want to get involved in politics in the future
, second question to
Ms. allen things, where are we in
social research here?
I've looked at it here now I
don't find this issue 20 21
particularly innovative I've accompanied all 6
issues I
really lack the commitment to civil society
why didn't they do any
formats and the wzb he has experience
on the route that the population
get in they have such urgent
tasks we have a
hostility to science we have opponents of vaccination
etc. we have an underdeveloped
science litteris you why aren't there any
new formats that take up
that that wouldn't be of any interest
to you for your institution such as
thank you
so much  that i like the themes and designs
concrete  also continue to carry and take with
me to the federal level it's clear hermlin
i haven't even gotten out of the car
has already said that
i'll definitely work on it mr müller i'll get the
concepts and papers there too but
also from my own conviction and
through what we do  also experience here because what
that triggers in
terms of communication possibilities, network formation, that's why I will also promote it, of course, at the federal level and we will now be ten
if and how I
can work with it in the SPD parliamentary group
, everything will only be clarified within the
next few days  weeks in the next week the federal parliament will be
constituted, then the committees
will be formed parallel to the
coalition negotiations and then you will
see where and how you can get
involved  when you think of the humboldt forum
now,
that's a huge task that motivates you to do so
is this forum to be used to make it
attractive to inspire with
the most diverse approaches that will
surely be found there I believe it
has to and it will also
develop further but at the moment I am
quite enthusiastic about the humboldt
lab I have to say what to see there it
actually yes  In the sense that we
are discussing here right now and
inspiring people together and with science to
show
what is there and what can become of it
, I understand that humor is still
in the environmental forum and that is
just an example of what I think
After a very successful appearance, there are other topics, e.g. the presentation of
the two humboldt
brothers, i think you can
clearly work on
changing and improving this in
the humboldt forum, so in that respect i see
it now with positive
aspects
that need to be further developed and what was successful or what needs to be done  to be
carried further well we have already succeeded in
that  speaking, i think
a lot in this
legislative period also in this
network building, how we position ourselves overall
in science and
research methods, so that we can also
have an impact on the outside, set impulses beyond berlin
, but you have to keep at it now,
you have to keep up with the
concrete implementation  many appointment
if we only think about the heart center
we have now agreed it should
come well now it has to come
now it also really has to be
implemented the claim has to be fulfilled
the digital largest most modern heart
center in europe that doesn't happen by
itself  that means the basics are there and
they have to be further supported in the next few years
there are other topics
with which we have also failed at
the federal level with berlin initiatives
we have introduced initiatives for the
Bafög reform a small
example I think but an important one and that
has caught up with us in d  he corona time
that i think the students weren’t
sufficiently supported that’s
something you could initiate from berlin
that we did that it was
n’t picked up nationwide means i
think it has to be conveyed further by me at the
federal level
anyway  you
stick with it then in the next one
the surcharge for the Bafög reform succeeds
insofar as we are i think in an
area of science and research where
you can never say a point has been reach
d you can say we have made it bu
there always has to be something there
is then also to be further developed
thank you sir ourselves for this question
what is not innovative for
you and is equally not innovative for me
what it
should be a matter of course it means through all formats
this year significantly more
young people people from other
countries women and so on  and so on
so the diversity is much more
within  b lived these forums i
understand that you don't
find this innovative i also think it's great that you
don't find this innovative the
science
however still has its work to do here that my
first answer is the second if you focus on
established formats such as for example where we are
proud of it  are bringing science to
the people that it's definitely
a part we're bringing science
to berlin to the people in berlin
through different locations that
will take place and we're bringing
people to science that's
what we also call transfer
if you  under science literacy and
something like that these are things that cannot be
limited to a week they can
not be limited to a year
we have to work on that there are
concepts you know and I also
accompanied
viscom and that's where we were  also important
this is something that has to become
standard but not limited
thanks to all the things we still have  five
minutes of
hermlin add a comment, sir,
we also have communication on this topic, we
also have the long night of science in berlin, that's
an
event that's primarily
aimed here at the city
because we're addressing other groups of people again
than
maybe as part of the balance heinz
away with the individual events it's
good to be truly
international
and i'd also say bringing an internationally
top-class audience here
to berlin that's something you should
also notice and differentiate of
course there is  as part of the balance
1 how many events are also possible for
the urban society
but i want to go back to the
difference between the long night of
science on the one hand and
the claim in connection with the
balance 1 like no word science
to make events with it  maybe just
a hint we  at falling walls we have
format that is called in front of the
brothel where we
only ask for nominations worldwide for
communication formats under the aspect of
skin type shock
curatorial
this is support of the bosch foundation
but also the wellcome trust of the moore
foundation etc. so 1 1 im
basically yes
, the topic is a hot topic worldwide
this year i think we had 230
or 250 nominations worldwide and of
course a proposal from nigeria
or sri lanka is different than one from
london new york or zurich
and the fantastic thing is if they
should come then  what i hope to
look at from those we
invited as finalists is that
you can develop very specific formats
, also related to regions, to
certain
population groups and so on, so
the topic is already very present, but
on the level you compare something like that
overall  is offered in the world and
then I think you can always go down
vomit what is interesting for berlin
maybe there are
suggestions where you say we or those
who are sitting on the podium here we can
also transfer them to berlin
thank you very much mr mlejnek i think
we are going to close many thanks to everyone
involved everyone who was in the audience
and  very happy to see you all at the
sixth balance 1 away many
thanks